BRADY HARAN: So that's the
Eurostar bringing people from
the continent here to London
for the Olympics.
And if you're in London,
you can't far
without seeing these.
Now, the Olympic rings are
pretty cool, but they're
joined in a bit of a
disappointing way, each one
joined to the one next to it.
It's not very creative.
Here at Numberphile, we like our
rings joined in a bit more
of a clever way.
JOHN HUNTON: We all know how
two rings can be linked.
So if I've got one ring and I
can link it with another one.
And that's how I can start
to form a chain.
And I can't pull those
two rings apart.
But the cute idea of a Borromean
ring is that you end
up with three rings.
Let's see if I can draw.
So that's going to
be my first ring.
And my second ring isn't
linked to it.
Like that.
See that one, if I filled in
the gaps, would be just
sitting on top of this one.
And then I put a
third ring in.
And this third ring is going to
go underneath my first one
and over my second one.
Now.
If you made that out of physical
pieces of metal,
you'd find that you couldn't
pull it apart.
Because take any two of those
rings, and it looks like they
could be pulled apart.
But the third one acts as some
sort of tie joining them
together in a way that
they can never
be physically expanded.
And I've got one here.
I took a course in silver
smithing some years ago, so I
used to make things like this.
And here we have three rings.
Arrange it like that so they're
each at 90 degrees to
each other.
And each one goes outside one
ring and inside the other.
But as you go around the rings
one, two, three, each is
inside outside, outside
inside, and so on.
So the whole thing hones
together, and you can't take
them apart.
So this is an example of
what mathematicians
call the higher linkage.
So this is a more complicated
way in which three things
could be band together,
than the two rings.
No two rings are linked together
in this sense.
BRADY HARAN: Does this only work
with the number three?
JOHN HUNTON: No.
Once you start playing with
these things, you realize you
could make a corresponding
entity out of any
odd number of rings.
It has to be odd.
Yes, it gets a bit fiddly if
you try to go beyond five,
unless you're making
it much bigger.
The other thing that you might
want to know about it is this
is much more familiar
as a braid.
And everyone knows how
to braid three
strips, three wires.
So if I had three ropes and I
braid by taking the middle
one, putting it over onto
the outer ones.
And then I will swap over
down this row, won't I?
So by that stage, I've swapped
everything around once.
I've got two overlaps.
Under, and then back to there.
So if you chase this blue one,
this first blue one.
So it's gone all the way
to the other side
and all the way back.
So this one is an under.
This other outer one going all
the way around here, and
that's come back to its end.
If I now join it up, if I solder
this end to this end,
and that end to that end, and
that end to that end, I'd have
three rings, and they'd
be linked in
exactly the same fashion.
BRADY HARAN:I tell you what
I take from that.
I think the professor is much
better at making rings than he
is at braiding hair.
JOHN HUNTON: Yes.
BRADY HARAN: If you want
to see a bit more about
interlinking rings, I've
actually done another video
just last week about how
chemicals can link
like this as well.
Hopefully floating there, you
can see a little preview of
the video, and you
can click on it.
There will also be a link
under the video.
So have a look at
that one also.
So I'm here in London, and I'm
going to beat up Henry.